[Musik]
im sächsischen großröhrsdorf führt der
neue radweg landschaftlich schön über
und am flüsschen press netz entlang
eigentlich sollten die radler hier auf
sechseinhalb kilometer butterweich
rollen auf einer brandneuen samt
geschleppten farbschicht tatsächlich
aber ist dieser fahrbahnbelag
dreieinhalb jahre nach der eröffnung
schon futsch die radler müssen auf
blankem schotter fahren oder besser sich
holland voran kämpfen also eigentlich
das einfach leute die sowas bauen oder
ich weiß es nicht waren dass sie auch
fachleute einsturzgefahr
verletzungsgefahr wenn man oft ihren
steilen die die räder
also ist man auch schnell mal umgekippt
der radweg war nicht billig satte 900
tausend euro kosten der weg und die
brücken und dafür so eine schotterpiste
beim bau auf einem ehemaligen bahndamm
hat man irgendwie das raue
erzgebirgskamm nicht einberechnet
regen und schnee waschen den weg aus
übrig bleibt nur die tragschicht aus
spitzen steinen die so keiner will die
gemeinde hat sich für diese bauweise
entschieden weil der weg stellenweise
durchs naturschutzgebiet verläuft dass
das zu problemen führt war den
verantwortlichen im rathaus von anfang
an klar also die bauweise in der
wassergebundenen oberfläche bringt es
eigentlich immer mit sich dass sich
schon nach kurzer zeit also schäden
einstellen die immer wieder behoben
werden müssen
sage und schreibe 1000 tonnen
fahrbahnbelag die ihn einfach so flöten
das ist doch ein klarer planungsfehler
oder als die planung würde ich nicht
bezeichnen weil der weg hat er vorher
gesagt viel viel schlechteren zustand
als wir herzlich darstellt und stand
eigentlich nur die möglichkeit man nimmt
die fördermittel und baut obermann lässt
bleiben nach kürzester zeit so eine
holperpiste für fast eine million euro
die radler sind bedient steine die das
sind umgefallen man kann das jetzt
wieder 23
und wieder können und was macht man dann
eine langfristige lösung ist also nicht
in sicht alle paar jahre werden die
bagger anrücken müssen und samt
nachfüllen der neue radweg wird zur
never ending baustelle werden